[Music]
hi
i'm gage's mom and i'm gonna offer him a
challenge a hundred dollars
to buy me a new year's eve outfit
they're gonna have a hundred dollars and
one hour
to actually find the best outfit she's
gonna be super excited when she finds
out
let's see if he's up for it so late so i
have a challenge for you
yeah guess what buzzfeed is giving you a
hundred dollars
to go and sell fun really yeah really
one hour one hundred dollars all of it
all of it and find me at best new year's
outfit because i think you have a better
professional sense that i'm a better
yeah i'll do it in less than an hour
watch one hour
three two now
[Music]
remember one hour so do you have a plan
um right now i'm looking at kohl's and
next i think i'm going to look at
macy's
what is it that you're looking for the
black one yeah
maybe i would ever wear anything like
that yeah
have you found anything um yes i found
one um like skirt it's blue
like with like silver buttons is that
something you think mommy would wear
yeah i think so i think it would look
nice on you for
the for the party
we're gonna leave it a little bit tucked
in but like
a little bit over oh sorry obviously
thinks i'm
way smaller than i am because this is a
size small
and i can't even get it past my hips and
now
so you think i would wear this no it
would wear because
i like the material this is usually what
you wear all the long stuff
that's correct okay now i'm going to
target
and categories
women okay about 10 minutes have gone by
so you have 50 minutes left
oh okay let's make sure we don't run out
of time
okay this one's not so bad okay so
that's the dress you want
how many dollars is that okay so how
much do you have left how many five
eighty-five okay so let's see what else
you can find i'm finding like
really fancy dresses um but like
that's not like what i'm looking for i'm
looking for like
simple dresses but like they they look
nice
oh i can sort by color my mom's favorite
color is purple so
all right this one looks very it's a
little dominatrix
[Music]
my daughter goes from picking
interview looking outfits to this one i
tell her it's new year's eve
next is heels what size are you uh eight
remember the dress is red so think about
which one would fit
you like these are you finding anything
nope oh i think i found another one it's
like
purple um and it has like
flower designs now is that something
that you like or something you think
mommy would like or both both i think
okay i could make it work she gets me a
good pair of heels
um so how much time is left 34
34. yeah i like the long boots you like
the long boots so you think love was
really really good with this dress
yes or no no do you like that wow
you're choosing you think that you know
better so let's see if you know better
so so far all i got is a dress it's
going good um i got
my leggings and the dress and i'm
looking at some ankle boots
i think um this one might be nice um
it's like
black and it has like a silver buckle on
the side with like a black strap
my pen boots my pink pants
a little jacket
[Music]
okay okay cute
okay what do you think oh this is my
wednesday adams
slash
do you like them for you would you like
them for me for me so you're not really
dressing me you're just dressing like a
barbie doll oh wait this is the color
so 15 dress and five dollar shoes
remember time's cooking okay let's see
where is the jewelry you know how much
money you've left to spend
um 19 left
and those pants do you think that's your
final okay why don't you add it up see
if we have enough money
and this okay all right do the math
all right so wait did you do the math
yeah which food is crazy for
104. all right we're gonna have to boot
something
do you think those hopes will go with
the dress and with those sure
am i 26 27 okay so 26 how much do you
have left
74. okay so do you think i should wear
pantyhose or no
santee hose is like um you know so that
my
my legs won't be cold oh i think mommy
will like these earrings because
they're like dangly and like they're
like
um leaves with like a red little berry
like mistletoe
you have 10 minutes left 10 minutes
oh geez so they went over budget
she's outside trying to find an
accessory we had to get rid of the
overcoat
are you gonna help me you gotta help me
you're gonna help me you think i need a
purse
yes all right so let's see so you think
this is the one that i should have
yeah why do i need to drag a child
because you're gonna be cold
in just a dress i just
added this necklace and now it says that
that i only have eighty-one in the car
that and i have a necklace and
earrings and they're like can you have
necklace earrings
and a bracelet it's up to you it's your
outfit
um like something that's like colorful
but
like that's like not just plain silver
and gold
running out of time i i'm hurrying up
you think that color would go on my
bread i think it'll be trendy
yeah yeah so we're wearing this jacket
okay
and how much was that 79 bucks is it
easier to shop for you than this to shop
for me
so hard to sell for female
we have 40 seconds left
and um we're actually
doing hanging right now okay
it's the last moment you gotta finish it
up
done so that was fun
yeah that was really fun i had a great
time baby thank you for picking
such a great outfit for me and
now we're going to
go upstairs in china so i'm really
excited to see her reaction to the
outfit
and i hope she really likes it yeah
so this is with the code on
okay and this this is the first that you
got me
i like the first
it's an awful lot that you find you
don't like the heels
so do you think this is something that i
would wear
you usually wear something sparkly and
something that family friendly
and this is not family friendly and why
is this not family friendly this is like
something you would wear at a club
this is really nice gage
i love how simple and nice this dress is
the buckles on the boots are so cool
i love pockets i chose this because i
like girls and red dresses
the dress was beautiful a little too
daring for me let's put it this way
what's your least favorite piece um the
handbag because i don't really wear
handbags across my chest but it's also a
for night out and for a night out i
don't need a big thicker bag
so thank you baby girl
you did a great job thanks
[Music]
you